aujourd'hui est ce qu'il y a une
résistance à droite face au populisme du
menu il n'y en a pas puisque la droite
est passé sous la domination des
populistes du mime et à plus de droite
la droite n'existe pas ya simplement une
espèce de brindilles de droite
affairiste qui existent et qui
considèrent que la politique c'est
exactement la même chose
comme si on faisait un troc et du
business la politique ce n'est pas 1 3
ce n'est pas un business et de l'éthique
deux filles s'est accompagné son pays
est développé en cours est son pays
c'est ça la politique moi je considère
que ce résidu de droite affairiste qui a
à la limite volontairement confondues
affaire est politique et dont un de
brimer le peuple martiniquais et attire
une proposition dite idéal socialiste
structurée de la commune is non parce
que les quelques 2 3 communistes à
transformer à la fois l'idée 1 mais
aussi la vocation de ce parti à une
espèce de lessivage de l'esprit pour
devenir que les sous fifres des
populistes du mime et n'ont même pas
honte de le dire et de le faire au fur
et devant tout le peuplement de y
at il des hommes dits modérés qui sont a
priori et on la considérait comme ça des
démocrates des gens qui ont une culture
politique et qui ont eu l'occasion de
fréquenter mais césaire pendant un
certain temps qu'ils ont eu l'occasion
de fréquenter ce banquier d'être mêmes
acteurs de ce parti est ce que lee assez
modérée de gauche qui pourrait nous sa
compagne et deux au combat ils ont aussi
complètement disparu
ce que je vaux devenus dépendants et
surtout des alliés politiques
je veux parler du rdr je le dis
clairement la seule opposition qui reste
aujourd'hui en martinique
fastré ça ce qu'il y a dans ce pays
c'est à 100 pour une martinique nouvelle
et d'un ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle c'est la parti progressiste
martiniquais